how do you want to do bumper cars dance
parties
now can you come pick lumberjack vibes
is it yummy
good hi i'm hannah i'm the world's
okaiest mom and i have one very
strong-willed toddler this is henry we
know him we love him
and henry very much likes getting his
way so guess what we're gonna do for a
whole week henry
we're gonna make him the boss do you
want to be the boss yeah yeah
henry's gonna be the boss yes
so wish us luck now putting a toddler in
charge for a week may seem like a
disaster waiting to happen but i'm not
sweating it because we know geico has
great insurance geico can help with all
kinds of insurance from your car to
truck suv home and more geico makes it
really easy for people like me and matt
to bundle home and auto insurance and we
could save a ton too
but it's far too quiet outside of my
room i gotta go see what henry's doing
quiet quiet is never good
henry is an incredibly opinionated
toddler um very frustrated in general
toddler and just incredibly particular
he thinks he's an only child and he
thinks he is also in charge of everybody
else
so i kind of want to see what happens if
he actually gets his way i think there's
a notion that oh i'm spoiling him by
letting him have his way but i found
with my kids when i listen to them and
when i acknowledge what they're
expressing and their needs it actually
develops a lot of trust between us so
henry is very clear about his wants and
needs throughout the day but i also want
to gamify this a little bit and make it
fun so i purchased a spinning wheel
we're gonna write all of henry's
favorite things on it and he gets to
spin it and that will determine what we
as a family do so the wheel arrives i
sit down with henry to write out the
options and i didn't realize how much of
a struggle this was gonna be because he
kind of has a default answer
to anytime you ask what his favorite
anything is and his answer is blue one
blue one
okay so he didn't have much to offer
when it came to the wheel because he
didn't quite understand that i was
asking him to list off his favorite
things to do what's your favorite thing
to do for fun um
blue one blue one we have blue one here
where do you like to go outside
i'm not you i cannot give you this
marker so henry was not much help in
coming up with options so i enlisted
jackson to help me come up with what to
write on this wheel trampoline car game
you're the car game you guys play dance
party jackson dyed his hair he has been
begging to have red hair i think it's
inspired by markiplier but i feel like
such an old lady i mix up all the
youtubers but i took him to the salon
and he got his hair professionally done
for the first time and he looks amazing
so the wheel ended up with trampoline
henry walk henry styles everyone arm
time play with wilder mama take head off
cereal bars dance party car game and
blue one some of those don't make any
sense but they will so just just keep
watching
are you gonna spin the wheel okay
[Music]
henry walk
so basically we like to go on a lot of
walks we have great hiking trails in our
neighborhood but henry is very
opinionated about the way in which he
participates in the walk looks like he's
ready for a walk
we get outside we're raring to go on
this walk and he decides
i don't want to walk i want to ride
bumper cars
how do you want to do bumper cars
we have a set of two bumper cars that i
actually got him for his birthday and
they're so cute and they have a remote
that the parent can control too but it's
the easiest electric vehicle that he can
operate and maneuver himself without
being dangerous so henry got in the
bumper car and we had to follow him the
only thing with this bumper car is it's
very slow so it was this weird like
funeral procession you know overall no
tantrums so that walk was a success in
my book maybe next time i'll let the
boys go ahead though
what does this say henry
dance party
let's do it
let's go dance party he loves to dance
he loves listening to music and jumping
around and just having a blast but he
really goes back and forth on
who is allowed to dance and what they're
allowed to do come on henry
oh oh i can't
so for this particular dance party i was
not allowed to dance
[Music]
i don't know what i did to deserve this
but i was not allowed to dance i was on
the outs and anytime i tried to move i
was completely shut down
so it was a kid's dance party apparently
i could never leave my camera unattended
without a little trolling but they're so
cute jackson's spinning on henry's
behalf
henry styles everyone today
we're gonna go to the zoo do you want to
pick everyone's outfit this is really
where he excels because he is
super into fashion he's super into
clothes and very particular about what
he wears
so i was really excited to see what he
would pick for everybody else
okay these pants okay get a shirt no we
can't just keep taking pants out get a
shirt
oh that's a great shirt so henry chose a
sheep shirt
and brown pants unfortunately
those brown pants no longer fit and he
had to pick a different pair of pants
what should mommy wear
these jeans
this
yeah
okay i don't have a full-length mirror
but
outfit
definitely not something i would
pick and i'm gonna need a jacket so
he'll pick that too but here we are
jackson actually tried to calm the
system by putting his favorite clothes
on the top of his drawers
so he did get his favorite pair of jeans
but then henry really dug deep and
pulled out this plaid
flannel button down that jackson
i don't think has ever worn because
jackson is very particular about his
clothes specifically shirts and he wants
everything to be
seven sizes too big and this is just a
little too fitted for him you're looking
really good thank you
i give jackson's outfit a 10 out of 10.
i thought he looked great and then for
himself henry insisted on wearing his
adidas he calls them his white shoes and
he absolutely loves them adidas if you
want to send me some backups i would
certainly appreciate it hilarious
me spin the wheel yeah
mom take head off you want to take my
head off yeah so probably the weirdest
thing on the wheel is mom take head off
and i truly don't know
where it came from why it happened what
it is but henry is obsessed with trying
to take my head off
wow you came close
so you take my head off yeah
okay
whoa
good job i feel like every toddler has a
weird
kind of like
impossible obsession not necessarily the
heads but just something weird
please let me know so i can feel better
so next the wheel landed on trampoline
time but we decided first to bring out
some treats to my chickens oh hi chicken
you want to give them their treats
what do we have for them
strawberry so you take this and you set
it on the ground okay
okay
set it down watch out don't step in no
no no okay put it down
put it down
no no no just leave it henry oh my god
chase the package
and then he hopped on the trampoline so
at this point halfway through the week i
feel like things are pretty easy um he's
being pretty manageable
and i think he's really happy in having
a little more autonomy
[Music]
wow
guess who's coming over
guess
what who's coming over
no
who's coming over
oh why dale wilder yeah yeah
i am not exaggerating when i say that
little kid friendships are the cutest
thing in the entire world henry has one
best friend well he has one friend he's
also his best friend his name is wilder
and he lives down the street they're
really close in age and they just love
each other who's here
[Applause]
so they're at that age where they're
actually playing together and
interacting and playing with toys but
they're very hot and cold with each
other but also obsessed with each other
at the same time i really love
encouraging them to play because wilder
is such a good influence on henry he is
really calm
he's a lot more gentle and he plays
really well with just about anyone he's
a great kid after they play henry is
always
in a really good mood and just a little
more
chill which i really appreciate thank
you wilder
should we spin i'll get you a cherry
no
here
hold on ready
good job
let's see
blue one
last but not least
couldn't have a henry week without a
blue one which i'm still trying to
figure out what it means not sure if
this blue one was a food or a toy or an
outfit pretty much everything is blue
one but if you saw in the other episode
where the kids meal planned the week and
i had to make blue one the kids were so
amped on the crepes that i made that i
decided to bring it back for this week
too
blue one 2.0 and i got my berry compote
this time i added more whole berries to
it
so there's a lot more because that was
very popular and i'm going to do this
one with honey and i even did whipped
cream and compote just to make this an
epic epic meal this is one of henry's
favorite foods of all time hands down
he's obsessed with whipped cream he's
obsessed with berry compote and he's
obsessed with crepes so he was really
happy henry is it yummy
how is it jackson
good thanks to blue one for ending the
week on a high note so at the end of
this week i was
actually a lot happier than i thought i
was going to be i have so many
apprehensions about henry no longer
being the youngest because he is so
happy being the youngest so i really
think he deserved this week i think also
it does teach good autonomy it teaches
good ways of expressing your needs and
wants and i think catering to some needs
and wants at his age is important there
is a kind way to communicate in an
unkind way and so if we encourage the
kind ways of communicating and show that
he gets the result he wants out of it i
think it just encourages that type of
communication even more i really
encourage trying this if you have a
toddler it's really funny to see what
they would do if they had their way so
that's all for now i'm hannah and henry
what did you think of your special week
baby blue you want to do blue nails
[Music]
okay till next time
[Music]
you